Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.comic Sandbrook. What is an exciting day for all fans of French politics is it not because today is the day that the result of the French presidential election 2022 is announced and we should say that we are recording this the week before so we don't know who will have been elected. But we know that it will either be Emmanuel Macron or Marine Le Pen. And I'm guessing, Dominic, that your money would be on the former. I probably would be, Tom. But this is a terrible way to kick off, because if Marine Le Pen has won,
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告版本、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.comic Sandbrook。对于所有法国政治迷来说，今天是多么激动人心的一天啊，不是吗？因为今天是宣布2022年法国总统大选结果的日子。我们应该说明一下，这期节目是在大选前一周录制的，所以我们还不知道谁会当选。但我们知道，结果不是埃马纽埃尔·马克龙，就是玛丽娜·勒庞。多米尼克，我猜你的赌注会押在前者身上。我大概会是的，汤姆。但这真是一个糟糕的开局，因为如果玛丽娜·勒庞赢了，
then you're just humiliating me in the eyes of the listeners with my terrible prediction. But no, we did, so Tom, we did the chancellors of Germany, didn't we, to tie in with Angela Merkel's retirement. So we thought it would be fun to do the presidents of France's Fifth Republic. So that's from 1958 onwards, to tie with um either the re-election of emmanuel macron or the um election of marion de pen depending on what's happened absolutely and um i think we found when we did the um the german chancellors that they were i mean they were they were kind of a much more remarkable collection of politicians than I had kind of appreciated before. We disgraced ourselves by laughing a lot at Helmut Kohl. Do you remember?
那你就是在听众面前让我出丑，嘲笑我那糟糕的预测。不过说真的，汤姆，为了配合安格拉·默克尔的退休，我们不是盘点过德国的总理吗？所以我们觉得，配合埃马纽埃尔·马克龙的连任或者玛丽娜·勒庞的当选——具体取决于实际发生的情况——来盘点一下法国第五共和国的总统应该会很有趣。也就是从1958年开始。绝对是的。而且我觉得，当我们盘点德国总理时发现，他们——我的意思是，他们比我以前意识到的要更为杰出。我们当时还因为拿赫尔姆特·科尔开了很多玩笑而感到有些羞愧。你还记得吗？
Yes, we did. About his German-ness. But also about Gerhard Schroeder. Yeah, the Lord of the Rings. And our condemnation of Gerhard Schroeder as a shyster, I believe, turned out to be very prophetic. We've been completely vindicated. We have been vindicated with that. So the French presidency, as you say, so when we looked at the German chancellors, of course, that's an institution that got set up in the immediate aftermath of the Second World War.
是的，我们记得。不仅笑他的德国特色，还笑格哈德·施罗德。对，还有“指环王”。而且我们当时谴责格哈德·施罗德是个骗子，现在看来，这个评价非常具有先见之明。我们完全被证明是正确的。我们在这一点上得到了证实。所以，正如你所说，当我们回顾德国总理时，法国总统这个职位当然是一个在二战刚刚结束的废墟中建立起来的体制。
The French presidency, as it has existed under the Fifth Republic, is a later creation, but it is a creation of the dominant French political figure who emerges out of the Second World War, who is, of course, Charles de Gaulle, General de Gaulle. Yeah, that's right. So for people who don't know, there have been five French republics since the French Revolution. So there was the first one in the 1790s. There was one in the 1848-52 that was basically subverted by Napoleon III, not a friend of the show. After the fall of Napoleon III, there was a third republic, 1870 to 1940. That basically was ended with the collapse in 1940
正如它在第五共和国时期所存在的那样，法国总统是一个稍晚的产物，但它是从二战中走出的、最具主导地位的法国政治人物创造的，这个人当然就是夏尔·戴高乐，戴高乐将军。是的，没错。所以，对于不太了解的人来说，自法国大革命以来，法国已经经历了五个共和国。1790年代有第一共和国。还有一个是1848至1852年的共和国，基本上被拿破仑三世（本节目可不欢迎他）颠覆了。在拿破仑三世倒台后，是第三共和国，从1870年一直持续到1940年。它基本上随着1940年的崩溃而走向终结。
against the Nazis in World War II. Then after the Second World War, they set up a fourth republic. Now, de Gaulle, of course, lots of people will know. We'll come to him in just a second. We will, by the way, do a podcast just about de Gaulle, won't we people will know we'll come to him just a second we will by the way do a podcast just about de Gaulle when we tell him at some stage yeah um but de Gaulle was the sort of face of the liberation and of um defiance during the second world war and the face of France really wasn't he yeah he was a genius he made himself the emblem of France he did and we'll come to that in just a sec because I think that's really important in the way that French presidents perceive their role and the French public perceive the French presidency.
当时是在二战中败给了纳粹。然后二战结束后，他们建立了第四共和国。现在，很多人都知道戴高乐。我们马上就会谈到他。顺便说一句，我们以后会专门做一期关于戴高乐的播客，对吧？大家会知道的，我们马上就会谈到他。顺便说一句，我们在某个阶段一定会做一期专门讲戴高乐的播客。是的。但戴高乐是二战期间法国解放和反抗精神的面孔，也是法国的真正化身，对吧？是的，他是个天才。他把自己塑造成了法国的象征。他的确做到了，我们马上就会谈到这一点，因为我认为这对于法国总统如何看待自己的角色以及法国公众如何看待法国总统来说非常重要。
But de Gaulle had sort of flounced out of French politics at the end of the war in 1946, partly because the Fourth Republic was going to have a very weak presidency. And it was going to basically be a sort of parliamentary republic in which the prime minister held all the power. The Fifth Republic comes into being in 1958, and it is associated very much with the Gaul, and it's created in the crisis surrounding the Algerian War of Independence. So France is torn apart by the Algerian crisis. It's sort of paralyzed. There's a coup, an attempted coup, basically, by the military who are fighting in Algeria. And de Gaulle is this sort of unifying figure who can resolve the crisis and avert a possible civil war. And de Gaulle insists that the Fifth Republic will be in his image,
但戴高乐在1946年战争结束时曾赌气退出法国政坛，部分原因是因为第四共和国将拥有一个非常弱势的总统制。它基本上会是一个议会制共和国，由总理掌握所有权力。第五共和国诞生于1958年，它与戴高乐紧密相连，并且是在阿尔及利亚独立战争引发的危机中创立的。当时法国被阿尔及利亚危机撕裂，近乎瘫痪。在阿尔及利亚作战的军方发动了一场政变，确切地说是一场未遂政变。而戴高乐正是能够化解危机、避免潜在内战的这种能够将各方凝聚在一起的人物。戴高乐坚持认为，第五共和国将完全按照他的形象来塑造，
with a really strong executive presidency. The president will basically have all the power. I mean, domestic policy, the sort of nuts and bolts will be left to the prime minister but it's the presidency who will who will embody france and and i think he de gaulle is like churchill in the sense that he as a as a even as a boy there's this amazing story that he rather like churchill famously a harrow said to another boy you know i can see that one day I will save London and the empire from invasion. De Gaulle wrote a story, you've seen this when he was 15, about a character called General de Gaulle who would lead France to victory over the Germans. So he has this sort of demented sense of his own importance, which actually is then completely vindicated because, of course, although he doesn't lead the French army to victory over the Germans, he does become the face of resistance in the Second World War.
拥有一个极其强大的行政总统制。总统基本上将拥有所有的权力。我的意思是，国内政策这种繁琐的日常事务将留给总理去处理，但总统将体现法国的形象。而且我认为戴高乐就像丘吉尔一样，甚至在他还是个孩子的时候，就有一个神奇的故事：就像丘吉尔在哈罗公学时那样，他曾对另一个男孩说：“我看得出来，总有一天我会从入侵中拯救伦敦和帝国。”戴高乐在15岁时写过一个故事，你读过这个故事吧，讲的是一个叫戴高乐将军的角色带领法国战胜德国人。所以他有一种对自身重要性的近乎痴狂的意识，而这种意识后来完全得到了证实。因为尽管他并没有带领法国军队战胜德国人，但他确实成为了二战中抵抗运动的化身。
But it's also, I mean, he has a sense of his own greatness, but he also has a sense of France's greatness, doesn't he? And in fact, I mean, he kind of says that France cannot be France unless it is great. Yeah. And our very first podcast, of course, was on the theme of greatness. And I think you could say that the thing about de Gaulle is that he is probably the last European leader who you would call great, with a great big capital G. And I think that that certain idea of France that de Gaulle talked about, it flutters like the tricolor over every french president and maybe a measure of how effective a president is leading france is is how convincing they are standing
但这也是——我的意思是，他有一种对自己伟大的意识，但他也有一种对法国伟大的意识，对不对？事实上，我的意思是，他曾说过，法国若不伟大，便不能称其为法国。是的。当然，我们的第一期播客就是以“伟大”为主题的。我想你可以这样说：关于戴高乐，最重要的一点在于，他很可能是最后一位你可以称之为“伟大”的欧洲领导人，而且这个“伟大”得用大写字母G来写。我认为戴高乐所谈论的那种关于法国的特定理念，就像三色旗一样在每一位法国总统头顶飘扬。而衡量一位总统领导法国是否有效的一个标准，或许就是看他们在站在
there and taking on the mantle i think that's absolutely right i think so de gaulle the nickname for him one of the nicknames for him by the way way, was the Great Asparagus. He's such a sort of tall, beaky man. And he clearly, I mean, you can even see it in sort of photos and newsreels and things. de Gaulle always had this presence and this sort of incredible sense of himself. I always think with de Gaulle and with a lot of French presidents, there's only a very thin dividing line between them and Inspector Clouseau. So Inspector Clouseau, the Peter Sellers character, has this tremendous sense of his own dignity. Even when he's being attacked by a dog
那里并承担起这份重任时有多么令人信服。我认为这完全正确，我也这么认为。戴高乐，人们给他的绰号之一，顺便说一句，叫做“大芦笋”。他就是那种身材高大、鹰钩鼻的男人。而且很显然，你看照片、新闻片或者其他影像资料就能发现，戴高乐一直有着这种气场和对自己无与伦比的感知。每当想到戴高乐和许多法国总统时，我总觉得他们和克卢索探长（Inspector Clouseau）之间只有一条非常薄的界限。彼得·塞勒斯饰演的克卢索探长，对自己有着极高的尊严感。哪怕他被狗袭击，
or his servants hiding in fridges. Right, exactly. When he's dressed in a knight's suit of armour and a disguise or he's disguised as a Swedish sea dog or whatever, or he's falling down the stairs. He has this immense sense of his own importance and his own seriousness. And de Gaulle has this tremendous sense of his own seriousness and of France's seriousness. France is a unique country with this kind of exceptional history and destiny.
或者他的仆人躲在冰箱里。没错，正因如此。当他穿着骑士的盔甲、乔装打扮，或者伪装成瑞典海狼之类的角色，又或者从楼梯上摔下来时，他都有一种对自己重要性和严肃性的无限自我认知。而戴高乐也对他自己的严肃性以及法国的严肃性有着极高的感知。法国是一个独特的国家，拥有这种独特的历史和命运。
And its duty is to lead the world towards civilization. And French presidents are expected to live up to that in a way that British prime ministers never are. I mean, a British prime minister can look kind of shabby and stand on a soapbox and have his hair all messed up and just be shambolic and all these kinds of things. And that's fine because they are merely the king or queen's servant. You know, they're the king's first minister or whatever. But a French president is france
它的责任是引领世界走向文明。人们期望法国总统能够不负这种期望，而英国首相则绝不会被这样要求。我的意思是，英国首相可以看起来衣冠不整，站在肥皂箱上演讲，头发蓬乱，甚至显得一团糟，诸如此类。这都没关系，因为他们仅仅是国王或女王的仆人。你知道，他们是国王的第一大臣之类的。但法国总统就是法国。
yes you know de gaulle thinks he is the reincarnation of joan of arc or i mean church apparently he said this to churchill and churchill said we've burned one joan of arc yeah well the only cross i have to bear is the cross of lorraine he said yes exactly so so he looks like a stick of asparagus but i think he he also looks like Julius Caesar in Asterix the Gaul. I know you haven't read, but Julius Caesar in Asterix looks very, very like de Gaulle. And de Gaulle always spoke of himself in the third person, like Julius Caesar did. And there is that sense of the dictator, the man of destiny who arises and seizes control of his nation. And I think the other thing about de Gaulle is that
是的，你知道，戴高乐认为自己是圣女贞德的转世。或者说，丘吉尔显然对他说过这话，而丘吉尔回答：“我们已经烧过一个圣女贞德了。”是的，好吧。“我必须背负的唯一的十字架，就是洛林十字架，”他曾说道。是的，完全如此。所以他看起来像一根芦笋，但我认为他看起来也像是《高卢英雄历险记》里的尤利乌斯·恺撒。我知道你没读过，但《高卢英雄历险记》里的恺撒看起来非常、非常像戴高乐。而且戴高乐总是用第三人称来指代自己，就像尤利乌斯·恺撒那样。那种独裁者的感觉，那种应运而生并夺取国家控制权的命运之子的感觉，是切实存在的。我想关于戴高乐的另一件事是，
he has something quite dictatorial about him, but he never goes the full dictator. Yeah, that's right. So there's always that kind of slight tension about him. So it's there when he... I mean, you describe him as Cusse, but I think that's a bit harsh about him. So it's there when he, I mean, you describe him as Cusse, but I think that's a bit harsh on him because he really does kind of create an image of himself as the saviour of France, almost from nothing. And more than that, he creates an image of France as a victor in the Second World War that is wholly disproportionate to the reality. But he kind of bluffs it through, doesn't he? He persuades Churchill.
他身上有某种相当独裁的特质，但他从未走向完全的独裁。是的，没错。所以他身上总是存在着那种微微的张力。因此，当他……我的意思是，你把他描述为像克卢索，但我认为这对他有点苛刻。所以当他……我的意思是，你把他描述为像克卢索，但我认为这对他有点苛刻，因为他确实几乎凭空将自己塑造成了法国的救世主。不仅如此，他把法国塑造成了二战中的胜利国，而这与现实完全不成比例。但他靠着虚张声势挺了过去，不是吗？他说服了丘吉尔，
And he persuades Eisenhower that he can be first into paris when paris is liberated in august 1944 no i mean the comparison with cluso i don't mean to that the goal is purely ridiculous i mean that there's only that the sense of this is the genius by the way the sense of dignity yeah is really really important to peter sellis's characterization of cluso but it's also really important to french presidents' sense of themselves. And you say the thing about dictators. So de Gaulle had been out of office. I mean, as I say, we'll do de Gaulle properly another time.
并在1944年8月巴黎解放时，说服了艾森豪威尔让他第一个进入巴黎。不，我的意思是，与克卢索的对比，我并不是说戴高乐完全荒谬可笑，我的意思是只有那种——顺便说一句，这是天才之处——那种尊严感，对于彼得·塞勒斯塑造克卢索这个角色真的非常、非常重要，而这对于法国总统对自己的认知也同样至关重要。你刚才提到关于独裁者的事情。所以戴高乐曾一度离开政坛。正如我所说，我们以后会好好聊聊戴高乐。
De Gaulle is this great war hero. He has retired at the end of the Second World War to Colombie-des-Eglises, which is the sort of now famous worldwide as de Gaulle's kind of home. Does it have two churches? I assume it does, yeah. And as you say, Tom, he has this great line, the first line of his war memoirs, All my life I've had a certain idea
戴高乐是一位伟大的战争英雄。他在二战结束时退休，隐居在科隆比双教堂村。如今这里作为戴高乐的故居已经闻名世界。这里有两座教堂吗？我想是的吧。正如你所说，汤姆，他有一句非常棒的名言，也就是他的《战争回忆录》的第一行：“我一生对法国……”
of France. And there he is, he's the sort of very Roman figure actually, isn't he, Tom? This sort of great gentleman in retirement. Waiting to be summoned. Absolutely. Waiting to be summoned. Then in 1958, Algeria, which is being presented to the French as part of France,
“都有某种特定的理念。”他就坐在那里，实际上是一个非常具有罗马风范的人物，对吧，汤姆？那种隐退的伟大绅士。等待着被召唤。绝对是的。等待着被召唤。然后在1958年，阿尔及利亚——当时被当作法国的一部分呈现给法国人，
and there are – what are there? There are about a million people, Europeans, in Algeria. France feels it has to sort of defend them. They're the pieds noirs. The army in Algeria is kind feels it has to sort of defend them. They're the pieds noirs. The army in Algeria is kind of loyal to them, doesn't want to give up on Algeria, feels it's being betrayed by the Republican politicians. There's all kinds of political turmoil. The army called for de Gaulle. De Gaulle says, you know, I'm willing to serve. And actually, even then in 1958, some people say he wants to be a dictator. And de Gaulle
那里有——有多少人？大约有100万欧洲人住在阿尔及利亚。法国觉得它必须保护他们。他们被称为“黑脚”（Pieds-noirs）。阿尔及利亚的军队某种程度上忠于他们，不想放弃阿尔及利亚，觉得自己被共和派政客背叛了。各种政治动荡不断。军队呼吁戴高乐出山。戴高乐表示，（我）愿意为国效劳。事实上，即便在1958年当时，也有人说他想成为独裁者。而戴高乐
actually makes a statement. He says, at the age of 67, I'm too old to be a dictator and de Gaulle actually makes a statement he says at the age of 67 I'm too old to be a dictator don't you think I'd be a dictator by now if I isn't one of the people who suspect he wants to be a dictator someone who will appear later in our story François Mitterrand exactly well François Mitterrand will make his name as an anti-Gaullist you know that's one of Mitterrand's great calling cards Jean-Paul Sartre said, I'm not a Jean-Paul Sartre fan by any means. He said of de Gaulle in 1958, I would rather vote for God because God is more modest.
实际上发表了一份声明。他说：“在67岁的时候，我已经老得不能再当独裁者了。”难道你不认为，如果戴高乐想成为独裁者，他早就这么做了吗？难道怀疑他想成为独裁者的人当中，有一个人后来会在我们的故事中出现吗？那就是弗朗索瓦·密特朗，没错。好吧，弗朗索瓦·密特朗将作为反戴高乐主义者树立自己的名声，你知道，那是密特朗的一张王牌。让-保罗·萨特说过——我可绝不是让-保罗·萨特的粉丝——他在1958年谈到戴高乐时说：“我宁愿投票给上帝，因为上帝更谦逊。”
That's a good joke. But anyway, de Gaulle does come in in 58. He insists that the constitution is rewritten. He has a referendum. So now you get this new institution, effectively, there have been French presidents before, but you get this strong executive presidency, in some ways stronger even than the United States presidency. Well, and longer, right? Because initially it's seven years.
这是个不错的笑话。但不管怎样，戴高乐在58年上台了。他坚持重写宪法，并举行了一次全民公投。所以现在你得到了这个新的体制。实际上，以前也有过法国总统，但你得到了一个强有力的行政总统制，在某些方面甚至比美国总统制还要强大。嗯，而且任期更长，对吧？因为最初它是七年制。
Seven-year term, but also you're not as dependent on the votes of the legislature. although there will be issues of so-called cohabitation where the prime minister is from another party doing domestic policy, the French president basically has complete power over foreign policy. Well, he's the king, isn't he? I mean, that's the other thing. It's that idea that France is kind of Oedipally haunted by the figure of the king that it got rid of in the revolution. Well, that's the funny thing, that France got rid of its king, but it has in some ways a more a more monarchical system monarchical system certainly than britain
七年任期，而且你对立法机构投票的依赖程度也没有那么高。尽管会有所谓的“左右共治”问题——即总理来自另一个政党并负责国内政策——但法国总统基本上对外交政策拥有完全的权力。嗯，他就是国王，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是另一回事了。那种感觉是：法国就像被它在革命中推翻的国王的幽灵所困扰。嗯，有趣的是，法国摆脱了国王，但在某种程度上，它拥有一个比英国
does yeah so the very first election that de gaulle fights as president is against meteron and we'll come to meteron later and de gaulle wins reasonably easily um and then he has this sort of he has this sort of period he's quite an old man, but he definitely has this sense of greatness. I mean, when you compare him with Harold Wilson, who's the British prime minister at the same time in the mid-60s, de Gaulle is clearly the more obviously, in a verticom, great man. And de Gaulle goes around sort of being very French. He goes to Quebec and he says,
更加君主制、更加君主化的体制。是的，戴高乐作为总统参加的第一场大选是对阵密特朗，我们稍后会讲到密特朗。戴高乐相当轻松地赢得了胜利。然后他迎来了这样一段时期——他当时已经是一位年纪挺大的老人了，但他绝对有一种伟大的意识。我的意思是，当你把他与哈罗德·威尔逊（60年代中期担任英国首相）进行比较时，戴高乐显然是那个更显而易见的、名副其实的伟大人物。戴高乐到处表现得非常“法国”。他去魁北克并说道：
Vive le Québec libre, which offends the Canadians, and he has to go home straight away and cut short his his visits i remember there was an outraged a fabulous uh british cartoon of him as the force to frap the um the nuclear missile yeah um which kind of sums him up really he's well he does stuff like he he france is still in nato but he refuses to have french troops under sort of nato command and they'll withdraw from nato's command structures he obviously twice vetoes britain's application to join the common market which is his way of thanking us for our help in world war ii he he has a sense does he not of france as not being beholden to the united states and he sees britain's uh special relationship with the united states or slavish dependency with the United States,
“魁北克万岁，自由魁北克！”这激怒了加拿大人，他不得不马上回家并缩短了他的访问行程。我记得当时有一幅极为愤怒、妙趣横生的英国漫画，把他画成“风力”核导弹（force de frappe）……这大致总结了他的特点。他做过这样的事：法国仍然留在北约，但他拒绝让法国军队受北约指挥，他们随后退出了北约的军事指挥结构。他显然两次否决了英国加入共同市场的申请，这是他感谢我们在二战中提供帮助的方式。他难道没有这样一种意识吗：法国不应该受制于美国，他将英国与美国的“特殊关系”或对美国的“奴性依赖”——
depending on what you prefer. De Gaulle definitely sees it being the latter as something to avoid. And so his ambition is to situate France between the United States and the Soviet Union. Yeah, that's right. He thinks of France as a sort of third force in between the... Which is a bit of an illusion, really, because France is clearly part of the kind of Western Alliance, a key part of the Western Alliance. And de Gaulle is an anti-communist. But it's, but,
取决于你更喜欢哪种说法——戴高乐绝对认为后者是必须避免的。所以他的雄心是将法国定位在美国和苏联之间。是的，没错。他把法国视为介于两者之间的一种“第三方力量”……这其实有点像是个幻觉，因为法国显然是西方联盟的一部分，是西方联盟的关键部分。而且戴高乐是一个反共主义者。但它，但，
but the illusion is really important that in an, an increasingly kind of Anglo-Saxon world, he needs to maintain France's kind of exceptionalism. And then in 1968, the, the great, again, a brilliant subject for a podcast, Tom, the événement of May 1968 when the students have this uprising. They're throwing cobblestones at the Parisian police and there's a general strike.
但这种幻觉非常重要：在一个日益盎格鲁-萨克逊化的世界里，他需要维护法国的某种特殊性。然后到了1968年，又是一个极好的播客主题，汤姆：1968年5月的风暴（événements），当时学生们爆发了起义。他们向巴黎警察投掷鹅卵石，并爆发了总罢工。
And a lot of this is because basically de Gaulle is now too old, too autocratic. To the younger generation, he just seems like a… He's not a hippie, is he? He's definitely not. And de Gaulle, interestingly, and not surprisingly in some ways for a man who's lived through the world wars, he thinks this is a revolution. And he famously basically disappears from Paris, vanishes, doesn't tell anyone where he's going,
很大程度上是因为戴高乐现在已经太老了、太独裁了。对年轻一代来说，他看起来就像一个……他可不是嬉皮士，绝对不是。而且有趣的是，对于一个经历过世界大战的人来说，这并不令人意外，戴高乐认为这是一场革命。他最著名也最典型地从巴黎消失了，无影无踪，没有告诉任何人他要去哪里，
flies to the French military base in West Germany, in Baden-Baden, and basically sort of throws himself on the mercy of General Jacques Massou, who's the commander of the French troops in West Germany, basically says, if I need to, do I have your support to go back and crush the revolution? And it obviously doesn't come to that. But I think with with 1968 you know it's clearly the end of an era and actually he flounces out again in april 1969 and very sorry i don't think he flounces i think flounces in his alley what he does no i think it's more
飞往西德巴登-巴登的法军军事基地，基本上可以说是向西德法军司令雅克·马叙将军寻求庇护，他基本上说，如果需要的话，我有没有得到你们的支持回去镇压这场革命？事情显然没有发展到那一步。但我想1968年显然是一个时代的结束，实际上他在1969年4月又一次愤然离职，非常抱歉，我认为他不是愤然离职，我认为他是在他自己的……他所做的是……不，我认为更像是
like king arthur heading off to avalon oh i think you're being very generous. For listeners who don't know, he struts off. They have a referendum on regional government, on the system of regional councils. And everybody says it's a bad idea. de Gaulle says, well, if you won't approve my referendum on regional councils, I'm out, I'm off. And the public don't vote for it. And he says, right, well, don't say I didn't warn you. And off he he goes a day or two later and that's the end of him and he dies within the year yeah he does yeah and i think that's flouncing i mean you may not think it's flouncing but i think it's i know i think i think it's a a dignified withdrawal really well it's fair that's fair inspector cluso that's actually i'll tell you one other thing about de gaulle he was asked by the writer andre
亚瑟王前往阿瓦隆一样。哦，我觉得你太慷慨了。对于不知道的听众来说，他是大摇大摆地走了。他们就地区政府、地区议会制度举行了全民公决。每个人都觉得这是个坏主意。戴高乐说，好吧，如果你们不批准我对地区议会的公决，我就不干了，我走人。公众没有投票支持。他说，好吧，别说我没警告过你们。一两天后他就走了，他的政治生涯就此结束，而且他在一年内就去世了。是的，他确实去世了。我认为这就是愤然离职，我是说你可能不觉得是，但我认为是。我知道，我认为这真的是一次体面的退场，真的。好吧，克鲁索探长，这倒也公道。其实，关于戴高乐，我还要告诉你另一件事，作家安德烈
malraux great kind of political novelist of the 20th century um who he most admired and who his great hero was and you know his answer Tom and I not Jane of Arc because that would be too obvious I guess it's not Jane of Arc it's Tintin oh very interesting yeah it's a good answer I thought no Tintin who was of course Belgian yes very peculiar yeah very strange anyway so that that's all really by way of preparation, isn't it? Yes. And in our best style, our preparation, our prologue, our forward has kind of taken up, what, 20 minutes or something. That's good.
马尔罗，20世纪伟大的政治小说家之一，曾问过他最崇拜谁，谁是他的伟大英雄，你知道他的回答吗，汤姆？不是圣女贞德，因为那太显眼了。我想这不是圣女贞德，而是丁丁。哦，非常有趣。是的，这是一个好回答。我当时想，不，丁丁，当然是个比利时人。是的，非常奇特。是的，非常奇怪。不管怎样，这些都只是作为铺垫，对吧？是的。按照我们最好的风格，我们的准备工作、序言、前言居然花了差不多20分钟左右。这很好。
De Gaulle is a great character, though. He is a great character. The other thing about De Gaulle, Tom. No, Dominic, we're going to do a whole episode on him. We can't stick to De Gaulle. I think, well, I just want to say one last thing about the goal before we get to the others so the others are all integral shadow and trying to be the gold or to some extent or meter on defining themselves against the goal but the goal is also unusual because to goal is is quite a family man so to
不过戴高乐确实是个伟级人物。他确实是个伟级人物。关于戴高乐的另一件事，汤姆。不，多米尼克，我们要为他做整整一期节目。我们不能只局限于戴高乐。我想，在讨论其他人之前，我只想最后说一说戴高乐。其他人都是不可或缺的配角，都在试图成为戴高乐，或者在某种程度上，密特朗是通过将自己与戴高乐进行对比来定义自己的。但戴高乐也很不同寻常，因为戴高乐相当顾家，所以戴
goal is famously absolutely devoted to his daughter and who had down syndrome and was the one person with whom he would open up and actually he asked him buried next to Anne um and he and he is and and when you see the sort of photos and stuff it's incredibly moving and actually given the behavior of all his successors that definitely marks him out as an anomaly because we're going to see a succession of men whose devotion to family values is at best um half-hearted so that those two those two themes and a girl um the goal's uh daughter and outrageous marital behavior yeah um lead us very neatly into the man who succeeds to go as president a man called george pompou, who we will introduce après le break. See you in a sec. I'm Marina Hyde.
高乐以绝对溺爱他的女儿而闻名，他的女儿患有唐氏综合征，那是他唯一愿意向其敞开心扉的人，事实上他要求将自己葬在安妮的旁边。而且当你看那些照片之类的时候，真是令人难以置信地感人。实际上，鉴于他所有继任者的行为，这绝对使他显得与众不同，因为我们将看到一连串的男性，他们对家庭价值观的奉献充其量也就是半心半意。因此，这两个主题——一个女孩，也就是戴高乐的女儿，以及出格的婚姻行为——非常巧妙地把我们引向了接替戴高乐担任总统的那个人，一个叫乔治·蓬皮杜的人，我们将在休息之后介绍他。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Now, Tom, it has been far too long since we have talked about our favourite sponsors. Well, it's one of our favourite sponsors anyway. I don't want to diss the other sponsors, but it's UnHerd, U-N-H-E-R-D, the online magazine that, as regular listeners will know, is always kicking back against herd mentality. So, Tom, they know their audience
以及提前获得现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。现在，汤姆，我们好久没有谈论我们最喜欢的赞助商了。好吧，无论如何，这是我们最喜欢的赞助商之一。我不想贬低其他赞助商，但这就是 UnHerd，拼写为 U-N-H-E-R-D，正如老听众所知，这是一个不断反抗盲从心理的网络杂志。所以，汤姆，他们很了解自己的受众，
because this week they have an article by one of our contributors, by one of our guests. So regular listeners will remember we did a podcast about African decolonization with Tommy Oulade. And he wrote an article for Unheard, Tom, which I would like to hear your thoughts about. It was called The Future of Anglicanism is African.
因为本周他们有一篇文章，作者是我们的撰稿人之一，我们的嘉宾之一。所以老听众可能还记得，我们曾与托米·乌拉德（Tom Oulade）一起做过一期关于非洲去殖民化的播客。他为 Unherd 写了一篇文章，汤姆，我想听听你的看法。文章名叫《圣公会主义的未来在非洲》。
And he said, basically, London is a very religious place. It's the most religious city in Britain becausericans are driving this kind of church membership and tom o'lardy says conservatives who want to renew christianity in britain should stop listening to justin wilby and the pope they should lobby for an open borders immigration policy for all the african countries that britain once colonized do you tom agree with this that's my question i read the article with great interest partly because i always enjoy reading tom who is always a fabulous writer writes beautifully very very interestingly and i thought this was a great topic on something that i've kind of been pondering as well i mean
他说，基本上，伦敦是一个非常宗教化的地方。它是英国最具宗教色彩的城市，因为非洲人正在推动这种教会成员身份的发展。汤姆·乌拉德说，想要在英国复兴基督教的保守派应该停止只听贾斯汀·韦尔比和教皇的话，他们应该游说实行开放边界的移民政策，针对英国曾经殖民过的所有非洲国家。汤姆，你同意这一点吗？这是我的问题。我怀着极大兴趣阅读了这篇文章，部分原因是我总是喜欢阅读汤姆的文章，他一直是个极棒的作家，文笔优美，内容非常非常有趣，而且我认为这是一个很好的话题，也是我一直在思考的问题。我是说，
the detail that tom includes in his essay that um the place in the country that is most hostile to gay rights is London. Seems very, very counterintuitive because you imagine, you know. Which do you think it would be? Which parts of the country are you about to diss? Well, I knew that it was London. Oh, did you? And I guess kind of living in Brixton, I'm kind of very aware of that,
汤姆在他的文章中收录的细节是，全国对同性恋权利最敌视的地方……是伦敦。这似乎非常非常反直觉，因为你会想象……你觉得会是哪里？你打算贬低全国的哪个部分？好吧，我知道是伦敦。哦，你知道吗？我猜住在布里克斯顿，我对此相当清楚，
that you can see people pouring out of, say, gay clubs at eight o'clock on a Sunday morning. And you can also see people in their Sunday best heading off to church. And it's kind of very, that's very much a kind of Brixton scene. So I thought it was really, really interesting, really stimulating. And I think he ends on a note of saying, you know, nothing be more christian than um the recolonization of the imperial capital by people um coming from countries that have been converted by he wrote it just for you i know i know so anyway it's a wonderful essay check it out check out everything else he has uh written uh and of course check out unheard well n-h-e-r-d and do you have a special offer yeah because here is the thing as as so often as the way with unheard there n-h-e-r-d and do you have a special offer yeah because here is the thing as as so
你可以看到人们从周日早晨八点的同性恋俱乐部涌出来。你也可以看到人们穿着星期天的正装去教堂。这在很大程度上可以说是布里克斯顿的景象。所以我认为这真的非常非常有趣，非常具有启发性。而且我认为他的结语是，你知道的，没有什么比帝国的首都经历由那些在被转化信仰的国家中生活过的人们所带来的重新殖民化更具有基督教色彩了。他写这篇文章就是为了你。我知道，我知道。不管怎样，这是一篇精彩的文章，去读读看吧，看看他写的所有其他东西，当然也要去看看 Unheard。拼写是 N-H-E-R-D。你们有什么特别优惠吗？是的，因为事情是这样的，正如 Unheard（拼写是 N-H-E-R-D）一贯的做法那样，你们有什么特别优惠吗？是的，因为事情是这样的，正如
often as the way with unheard there is a special offer for rest is history listeners now it is normally one pound a week some listeners may know these words off by heart by now it is normally one pound a week but our listeners will get their first 10 weeks free i mean they are literally giving it away and for that you will get four long pieces today, hard-hitting, penetrative, insightful essays. You will get a podcast. A podcast? I didn't read that. But you get another podcast.
Unheard 一贯的做法那样，为《历史其余部分》的听众提供了一项特别优惠。通常是一周一英镑，有些听众现在可能对这些话烂熟于心了，通常是一周一英镑，但我们的听众可以免费获得前 10 周的体验。我的意思是，他们简直是在白送。为此，你今天可以读到四篇长文、力度强劲、透彻深入、见解深刻的文章。你还会得到一个播客。一个播客？我没看到那条。但你得到了另一个播客。
You should obviously listen to our podcast. I'm sure that's quite good as well. You'll get YouTube interviews. We don't do those, so you're free to watch the YouTube interviews without feeling any trace of guilt. And that will all be showcasing new and independent thinking. And as you surely all know by now, you get that by going to unheard.com slash rest. That's U-N-H-E-R-D dot com slash rest. Bienvenue. Welcome back to The Rest is History. So, Georges Pompidou, who will be most famous as the man who gives his name to the... It's weird, isn't it? He's most famous as a centre.
你显然应该听我们的播客。我相信那个也挺不错的。你会得到 YouTube 采访。我们不做那些，所以你可以自由观看 YouTube 采访，而不会感到一丝内疚。所有这些都将展示新的和独立的思想。正如你们现在肯定都知道的那样，访问 unheard.com slash rest 就可以获得这些。网址是 U-N-H-E-R-D 点 com 斜杠 rest。欢迎。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。那么，乔治·蓬皮杜，他最著名的身份是那个为……提供名字的人。这很奇怪，不是吗？他最著名的身份是一个中心。
Well, yes, he's most famous for having his intestines on the outside. Yes, I guess so. So the great kind of museum of modern art. And that, of course, is also a huge theme running through the French presidency is they're very, very fond of their grand projet, their kind of cultural achievements in a way that British prime ministers are simply not. But I mentioned the link with Anne de Gaulle. So Georges Pompidou, he is kind of from the Auvergne, I think, isn't he? He is from the Auvergne, yeah. Parents of farmers and
好吧，是的，他最著名的是他的肠子长在外面。是的，我想是的。所以那个伟大的现代艺术博物馆。当然，这也是贯穿法国总统任期的一个巨大主题，他们非常非常喜欢他们的宏伟工程，即他们的某种文化成就，这是英国首相根本没有的。但我提到了与安妮·德高尔的联系。所以乔治·蓬皮杜，他有点来自奥弗涅，我想是的？他来自奥弗涅，是的。父母是农民，
things uh yeah very rural area and he like a subsequent um french president ends up working for uh the rothschild bank yes yes i i hadn't thought of the link but obviously he and macron have then yeah um but he's then recruited from the rothschild bank by de Gaulle to go and work for the Anne de Gaulle Foundation. That's right, he did. He had worked for de Gaulle before, Tom. He had been a sort of apparatchik for him, factotum. But you're right, he did work for the Anne de Gaulle Foundation. How would we describe it?
诸如此类。是的，非常乡村的地区。他和后来的某位法国总统一样，最后去罗希尔银行工作了。是的，是的，我没想到这个联系，但显然他跟马克龙后来都有……是的。但他随后被戴高乐从罗斯柴尔德银行招募去安妮·德高尔基金会工作。没错，他确实去了。他以前为戴高乐工作过，汤姆。他曾是戴高乐的一类幕僚、全权代表。但你说得对，他确实为安妮·德高尔基金会工作过。我们该如何形容他呢？
I mean, he has huge Dennis Healy-style eyebrows. He's a cross between – I was thinking about this while I was researching it, obviously about the key historiographical questions. And it struck me the best way to describe George Pompidou for people who haven't seen him. And this will mean nothing whatsoever to overseas listeners. He is literally a cross between Dennis Ely and Ray Reardon. Yeah, good shout. Okay, well, I think what you should do for overseas listeners who may not be familiar with either of them is to put up a tweet or something on the Discord showing what they look like.
我的意思是，他有着巨大的丹尼斯·希利式的眉毛。他介于……我在做研究时一直在思考这个问题，显然是关于关键的史学问题。这让我觉得，对于没有见过他的人来说，描述乔治·蓬皮杜的最好方法是……这对海外听众来说完全没有任何意义。他简直就是丹尼斯·埃利和雷·里尔顿的结合体。是的，说得好。好吧，我想你应该为那些可能对他们两人都不熟悉的海外听众在 Discord 上发个推特或什么的东西，展示一下他们长什么样。
He looks like a man who might have managed Huddersfield Town in 1927. That's fair. Yeah. So he's not a man who exudes a sense of greatness. I think it would be fair to say. No, but he was actually a pretty good president. So he succeeds. Absolutely.
他看起来像一个可能在 1927 年执教过哈德斯菲尔德镇的人。这倒很中肯。是的。所以他不是那种散发着伟大感的人。我觉得这样说挺公道的。不，但他实际上是一个相当不错的总统。所以他继任了。绝对是的。
Okay. But, Dominic, before we get on to that before we get on to the succession his election yeah his election exists in the shadow of a sex scandal are you are you familiar i'm not familiar with this and the markovitch scandal no because you're very excited about it and so i'm greatly looking forward to hearing okay so stefan markovitch yeah uh he was the bodyguard of uh Alain Delon famous French actor very good actor at the time was starting out on his career and used to hold sex parties Alain Delon or the driver Delon and Markovitch would film them and supposedly Pompidou's wife was at one of these sex parties and there were all kinds of rumors of blackmail and um
好的。但是，多米尼克，在我们讨论这个之前，在我们讨论他的继任、他的选举之前……是的，他的选举笼罩在一场性丑闻的阴影之下。你熟悉吗？我对这个不熟悉，马尔科维奇丑闻。不，因为你对此非常兴奋，所以我非常期待听到。好的，那么斯特凡·马尔科维奇，是的，他是阿兰·德龙的保镖，阿兰·德龙是当时刚开始职业生涯的法国著名演员、非常优秀的演员，他过去常常举办性爱派对，阿兰·德龙或者德龙的司机，而马尔科维奇会把它们拍下来，据说蓬皮杜的妻子曾出席了其中一个性爱派对，并且有各种关于敲诈勒索的谣言，以及
extortion and all this kind of stuff going on and pompadour thought that this had been leaked by de gaulle and so that contributed to his his bust up with de gaulle also the fact that de gaulle hadn't told him that he was scarpering off to germany during uh yeah the events of 1968 um and pompadour said that it wasn't his wife but a prostitute who looked exactly like his wife Germany during the events of 1968. And Pompidou said that it wasn't his wife, but a prostitute who looked exactly like his wife. But of course, I mean, Pompidou's wife must have been in her 60s. Was Delon hiring sextuagenarian prostitutes?
勒索和所有这类事情正在发生。蓬皮杜认为这是由戴高乐泄露的，这导致了他与戴高乐的决裂。还有这样一个事实，即戴高乐没有告诉他在 1968 年事件期间他溜去了德国，是的……蓬皮杜说，那不是他的妻子，而是一个长得跟他妻子一模一样的妓女。在 1968 年事件期间逃到了德国。蓬皮杜说，那不是他的妻子，而是一个长得跟他妻子一模一样的妓女。但当然，我的意思是，蓬皮杜的妻子当时一定已经 60 多岁了。难道德龙在雇佣六十多岁的妓女吗？
That seems very implausible because Alain Delon was a very good looking young man. They order things differently in France. This is the kind of stuff that goes on. Alan Delon had a, had a Macronian attitude to these attitudes, clearly. Anyway, so much so Markovic, Markovic,
这似乎很不合情理，因为阿兰·德龙是一个长相非常英俊的年轻男子。法国人的行事方式不同。这就是正在发生的事情。阿兰·德龙对这些态度有着马克龙式的态度，显然。无论如何，以至于马尔科维奇，马尔科维奇，
Markovic got found dead. And, um, there was a kind of snarl of who'd killed him, uh, who, who this woman was, was it the prostitute?
马尔科维奇被人发现死了。而且，有一种关于是谁杀了他、这个女人是谁的争论，是那个妓女吗？
Was it Pompidou's wife? Anyway, so this is the first of many such scandals. Yeah. That have, uh yeah that have uh that will be enlivening this narrative i think but just so i just wanted to put that on the record that that is that is kind of the backdrop to uh pompadour coming to power and you're right that he's a very very effective president i mean very effective much more effective than than say contemporary british prime ministers wouldn't you say i mean he's uh well he's he yeah because he coincides i mean he's uh well he's he yeah because he coincides with ted heath yeah but he's but um pompadour is the sort of father of
是蓬皮杜的妻子吗？不管怎样，这是许多此类丑闻中的第一起。是的。这些丑闻将会……是的，将会为这段叙述增添活力，我想。但我只想把它记录在案，这就是蓬皮杜上台的背景，你说得对，他是一位非常非常高效的总统。我的意思是，非常高效，比当代英国首相高效得多，难道不是吗？我的意思是，他……好吧，他……是的，因为他与泰德·希斯同时代，是的，但是……但是蓬皮杜某种程度上是
the tgv the french high-speed trains the nuclear program i think yeah all these kind of great concord and france is in a in a better condition than britain i think in the late 60s early 70s france has overtaken britain in its gdp it is a bit more um self-confident i think um a bit less i mean of course france is divided in various ways but it's it's it's more comfortable with its divisions i think than than 70s britain and it has had what the the trot glories it has 30 years of kind of economic recovery i'll tell you a couple of other things about george pompadour so george pompadour is the french president who everybody kind of forgets, apart from his centre. He is the sort of – people are tired of de Gaulle,
TGV（法国高速列车）、核计划之父，我想是的，所有这些伟大的协和式飞机，而且法国在 60 年代末 70 年代初的状况比英国要好，我认为法国的 GDP 已经超过了英国，它更加自信一些，我认为……稍微不那么……当然，法国在各个方面都存在分裂，但它对自身的分裂比 70 年代的英国更感到自在，并且它经历了所谓的“光辉三十年”，即三十年的经济复苏。我还要告诉你关于乔治·蓬皮杜的其他几件事。所以乔治·蓬皮杜是那个除了他的中心之外，每个人都快要忘记的法国总统。他有点像……人们对戴高乐感到厌倦了，
so they don't mind having Pompidou. He's a bit more of a pragmatist. Well, he's John Major to de Gaulle's Mr. Thatcher. That's exactly what he is. And so it's obviously – he is the one president who's not expected to play de Gaulle because he's the morning after, if you like. The two things I was going to say about Pompidou is Pompidou, in very French style, is also the author of an anthology of French poetry. Well, he studied literature.
所以他们不介意由蓬皮杜来当。他更多是一个实用主义者。好吧，他就是戴高乐的撒切尔夫人先生所对应的约翰·梅杰。他就是那样的人。所以很明显——他是唯一一个不被期望扮演戴高乐的总统，因为他是雨过天晴之后的人物，如果你愿意这么说的话。我要说的关于蓬皮杜的两件事是，蓬皮杜具有非常法国式的风格，他也是一本法国诗歌选集的作者。好吧，他学的是文学。
Yeah. He was a literature professor, which is still used, I think, in some French schools, the Pompidou anthology, which is, again, you don't see that from Ted Heath. But presidents in France are meant to be cultured, right? They are. Pompidou had an excellent thing to say about history in his place in history. Did you see this, Tom? No. He said, happy people are not noted in history. I therefore hope historians do not have much to say about my term in office. And we don't. Not really. Not really. I mean, it obviously ended. The other interesting thing about Pompidou is the way it ended. So he's a pragmatist, he's a technocrat, he's sort of centre-right. His presidency is, I think in retrospect, reasonably successful.
是的。他曾是一名文学教授，这本蓬皮杜诗集至今仍在一些法国学校里使用，这也是你在泰德·希斯身上看不到的。但法国的总统们本就应该是有文化的，对吧？确实如此。蓬皮杜关于历史以及他在历史上的地位有一句绝妙的话。你看到了吗，汤姆？没有。他说，幸福的人在历史中是籍籍无名的。因此，我希望历史学家们对我的任期不要有太多可说的。我们确实没有。没有多少。我是说，这显然结束了。关于蓬皮杜，另一个有趣的事情是它结束的方式。所以他是一个实用主义者，他是一个技术官僚，他有点偏向中右翼。回想起来，他的总统任期我认为是相当成功的。
But it ends very abruptly in April 1974 when he dies in office of a very rare blood cancer. And actually the truth of the matter is Pompidou had known he was ill. And this is another theme of the French presidency. Very secretively, he had managed to keep it, not just from the public, but also a lot of his own colleagues. He dies. And he dies four days before the Eurovision Song Contest is due to be held in Brighton in 1974. So the French withdraw from the Eurovision Song Contest. As a mark of respect for George Pompidou. And it was just as well that they did.
但它在 1974 年 4 月戛然而止，当时他在任内死于一种非常罕见的血癌。事实上，真实情况是蓬皮杜一直知道自己生病了。这也是法国总统任期的另一个主题。他非常隐秘地将病情隐瞒了下来，不仅瞒过了公众，还瞒过了他自己的许多同僚。他去世了。他去世时距离 1974 年在布莱顿举办欧洲歌唱大赛还有四天。因此，法国退出了欧洲歌唱大赛。以此来表达对乔治·蓬皮杜的敬意。他们这样做也算是合情合理。
Because do you know the song that won the Eurovision Song Contest in 1974? Had Pompidou just met his Waterloo, Tom? Oh, the irony. Golly, thank goodness they didn't go. The irony. So ABBA won and obviously did not dedicate it to no it would have been yeah that would have been would have been insensitive so the departure of pompadour paves the way for perhaps the most in some ways the most entertaining of french presidents i think um and some ways also
因为你知道1974年欧洲歌唱大赛的冠军歌曲吗？汤姆，蓬皮杜刚刚遇到他的滑铁卢了吗？哦，真是太讽刺了。天哪，谢天谢地他们没去。真讽刺。所以ABBA赢了，显然没有把它献给……不，这会是……是的，那会是……那会是麻木不仁的，所以蓬皮杜的离开为也许在某些方面最引人注目的法国总统铺平了道路，我想嗯，在某些方面也是
my least favorite well i would say definitely the the french president who looks most like he would have been guillotined but also the one who looks most like a French president provided by a casting agency. Yeah, well, I mean, they're pretty much the same thing. Yeah. So even his name sounds like he belongs on a tumbril. Valéry Giscard d'Estaing. So Valéry Giscard d'Estaing, the world's haughtiest man, his grandfather apparently had added Destang to the family name to make them seem aristocratic. But the Destang were a very distinguished medieval family.
我最不喜欢的……好吧，我可以说，绝对是那个看起来最像会被送上断头台的法国总统，但也是那个看起来最像选角公司提供的法国总统的人。是的，好吧，我的意思是，它们几乎是一回事。好吧。所以连他的名字听起来都像属于一辆运囚车。瓦莱里·吉is卡尔·德斯坦。所以瓦莱里·吉斯卡尔·德斯坦，世界上最傲慢的人，他的祖父显然把“德斯坦”加到家族姓氏中，让他们看起来像贵族。但德斯坦家族是一个非常显赫的中世纪家族。
And shamelessly, later in life, did you see this? Valery Zhigardestan bought the Destang castle. With his brother. Yeah. So the d'Estaing, I mean, they went right the way back to, I think one of them saved Philip Augustus at the Battle of Bavine, and they got up to all kinds of stuff, went on crusades and things. Wow. The very last of the d'Estaing was an admiral who I think had served in the American Revolution on the French side, American side, but then ended up guillotined.
而且毫无廉耻地，在晚年，你看到这个了吗？瓦莱里·日加尔·德斯坦买下了德斯坦城堡。和他的兄弟一起。是的。所以德斯坦家族，我的意思是，他们一直追溯到，我想其中一个人在布汶战役中救了腓力·奥古斯都，他们参与了各种各样的事情，参加了十字军东征之类的。哇。德斯坦家族的最后一个人是一位海军上将，我想他曾以法国这一边、美国这一边的身份参加过美国革命，但最终被送上了断头台。
And so this is the guy that Giscard d'Estaing is kind of modelling himself on. Yeah, being a 70s politician and trying to model yourself on guillotine aristocrats is absolutely ludicrous behaviour, but absolutely true to Giscard d'Estaing's character. So he's born in 1926, isn't he? He was in the resistance. He was in the army. Like so many of the people who we're going to talk about, he goes to the two institutions. I mean, people talk about British politics as kind of class-ridden and introverted and a narrow cabal and all this,
所以这就是吉斯卡尔·德斯坦试图模仿的人。是的，作为一个70年代的政治家，试图模仿断头台贵族是绝对荒谬的行为，但完全符合吉斯卡尔·德斯坦的性格。所以他出生于1926年，不是吗？他参加过抵抗运动。他参过军。就像我们要谈论的许多人一样，他去了那两个机构。我的意思是，人们谈论英国政治时，认为它充满阶级色彩、内向、是一个狭隘的小集团等等，
but everybody in this story goes to one of two places. They go to either a place called Sciences Po, which is where you do political science, or they go to the École Nationale d'Administration, ENA, and that's where Giscard went. And he is a pure technocrat. He's an ENA. He is an ENA and he is a pure technocrat he's an anarch he is a he's a mandarin but dominic also just before we get on to that you also said that you know he'd served
但这个故事里的每个人都去了两个地方之一。他们要么去一个叫“巴黎政治学院”的地方，那是你学习政治学的地方；要么去“国家行政学院”（ENA），吉斯卡尔就是去的那里。他是一个纯粹的官僚。他是一个ENA，他是一个ENA，他是一个纯粹的官僚，他是一个文官，他是一个……但是多米尼克，在我们继续之前，你也说过他曾服役
in the resistance and actually the role that people play in the second world war and i suppose also in the algerian crisis i mean this that's also very very important isn't it yeah you've got to have had a good war you've got to have had a good war you've got to have had a good war and i think all these people obviously to go um g scar being in the resistance later on meet him interesting one yeah it's slightly more conflicted but um you're right yeah g scar comes in he's 48 years old um he's definitely a new generation uh he's a modernizer and um he's modernizing and i think is less successful than pompadour's because the one thing that g sky is really famous for is embracing a thing called
在抵抗运动中，实际上人们在第二次世界大战中所扮演的角色，我想还有在阿尔及利亚危机中，我的意思是这也是非常非常重要的，不是吗？是的，你得有一段光荣的战争经历，你得有一段光荣的战争经历，你得有一段光荣的战争经历，我想所有这些人显然去……吉斯卡尔后来加入抵抗运动，这算是一个有趣的例子，是的，稍微更复杂一些，但是……你说得对，是的，吉斯卡尔上台时48岁，嗯，他绝对是新一代，嗯，他是一个现代主义者，嗯，他正在推进现代化，而且我认为这不如蓬皮杜的成功，因为吉斯卡尔真正出名的唯一一件事就是拥抱了一个叫做
minitel have you ever used minitel no i haven't but that's the french um internet yeah that's the french version of the internet so people see facts yeah it's basically well we had a thing called prestel did you ever know but we didn't really push it whereas the french absolutely went all in so when i lived in france in the 1990s they were still the internet had come along but they were still desperately sort of flogging their kind of beta max version of the internet the minitel thing um which was sort of so minitel was like you've got a little terminal and um if you ever if you lived in the 80s and you ever read sort of predictions what the future would be like and what people would use computers for, that was what Minitel was.
米尼泰尔（Minitel）的东西，你用过米尼泰尔吗？不，我没用过，但那是法国的……互联网，是的，那是法国版的互联网，所以人们看事实……是的，基本上，嗯，我们有一个叫普雷斯特尔（Prestel）的东西，你知道吗？但我们并没有真正大力推广，而法国人则是全盘接受。所以当我在90年代住在法国时，互联网已经出现了，但他们仍然拼命地兜售他们那种类似BetaMax版本的互联网——米尼泰尔，这有点像……所以米尼泰尔就像你有一个小终端，嗯，如果你生活在80年代，你曾读过对未来的预测，以及人们会用计算机做什么，那就是米尼泰尔的样子。
You know, you could do your horoscope. You could order some groceries that would arrive in a month. Order a jet pack. Yeah, you could book very complicated train tickets. Well, on the TGV, which, of course, he's also pushing. Yes, that's right. That's more successful. And actually he does.
你知道的，你可以查星座运势。你可以订购一个月后才会送到的杂货。订购一个喷气背包。是的，你可以预订非常复杂的火车票。嗯，在TGV上，当然，这也是他大力推行的。是的，没错。这更成功。事实上他也确实这么做了。
I'm being mean to him because he does do other things. He better pensions and divorce reform and he legalizes abortion. And he does sort of other sort of 60s, 70s kind of modernizing. Well, he brings in Simone Vale, right? Right, he has female cabinet ministers. And actually, I'll tell you who the parallel for Giscard d'Estaing is. He's actually Jimmy Carter. So Jimmy Carter came to power at a similar time in America
我对他是有点苛刻，因为他确实做了其他事情。他改善了养老金和离婚改革，并将堕胎合法化。他还做了一些其他60年代、70年代式的现代化事情。嗯，他引进了西蒙娜·韦伊，对吧？对，他有女性内阁部长。事实上，我来告诉你谁是吉斯卡尔·德斯坦的对照版。他其实就是吉米·卡特。所以吉米·卡特在差不多相同时期在美国上台
and was very much sort of, I'm going to be a populist, I'm going to be in touch with the people. And Giscard tries that at first. Well, he goes on the metro, doesn't he? He goes on the metro, he has dinners with the public, and at one point he has some dustmen for Christmas to the Elysee Palace. And the polls show that the French public hate this
并且非常具有……我要成为一个平民主义者，我要贴近人民。吉斯卡尔起初也尝试了这一点。嗯，他坐了地铁，不是吗？他坐地铁，和公众共进晚餐，有一次他在爱丽舍宫和一些清洁工共度圣诞节。民调显示法国公众讨厌这一点
because they expect the president to be kind of sunken so he then just spends the rest of his life at the other this was just a feeble gesture that he didn't mean at all and so he spends the rest of his life trying to make up for this and actually when you go through the giscard d'estang stories they are absolutely he does things like he goes hunt he Poland and gets the French Air Force to supply him with hunting – to fly hunting rifles. He – at state dinners, when he's not dining with another head of state, he has the seat opposite him removed so he doesn't have to look anyone in the eye.
因为他们期望总统表现得高高在上，所以他接下来的余生都在……这只是一次他根本不是认真的微弱姿态，所以他余下的生命都在试图弥补这一点。事实上，当你回顾吉斯卡尔·德斯坦的故事时，它们绝对是……他会做一些这样的事情：他去波兰打猎，并让法国空军为他运送狩猎步枪——用飞机运送。他在国宴上，当不与另一国元首共进晚餐时，他会让人把对面的座位移走，这样他就不用和任何人对视了。
When Mrs. Thatcher entered the scene in Britain in 1979, he wouldn't have her put next to him at dinner because she was a mere head of government and he was a head of state. And she got her own back by... Seating him opposite portraits of Nelson and Wellington, which I think is absolutely splendid behaviour. So he behaves in this incredibly ludicrously kind of haughty way. And that, I think, comes back to bite him at the end of the 70s.
1979年撒切尔夫人登上英国政坛时，他不让她坐在自己旁边进餐，因为她只是一个政府首脑，而他是国家元首。而她以其人之道还治其人之身……把他的座位安排在纳尔逊和威灵顿画像的对面，我认为这是绝对精彩的行为。所以他的行为极其荒谬地傲慢。我认为这在70年代末对他造成了反噬。
Well, also what comes back to bite him is his relationship with a friend of the show, Bacasa. Emperor Bacasa. Emperor Bacasa, who we talked about in the 12 Days of Christmas. We did. Who gives him a load of diamonds, doesn't he? That's right. And so Bacasa is this sort of parodic African dictator of the 1970s
嗯，同样对他造成反噬的，还有他与本节目老朋友巴卡萨的关系。巴卡萨皇帝。巴卡萨皇帝，我们在“圣诞节的12天”里谈论过他。我们确实谈过。他送了他一堆钻石，不是吗？没错。所以巴卡萨是1970年代那种讽刺性的非洲独裁者
for people who don't know, who runs the Central African Republic and crowns himself emperor at this incredibly lavish ceremony modeled on napoleon's coronation and he spends kind of 90 of the entire country's gdp on yeah on his own coronation but he also finds time to give giscard these diamonds because french presidents at this point as part of their sort of self-image as a counterweight to the United States. They're spending a lot of time trying to build up influence in kind of post-colonial Africa. And Giscard takes these diamonds from Macassar. This is then exposed by the French satirical magazine, Le Canard Enchaîné. And Giscard goes ballistic, says it's an absolute disgrace that people are accusing him of taking
对于不知道的人来说，他统治着中非共和国，并在模仿拿破仑加冕的极其奢华的仪式上给自己加冕为皇帝，他把整个国家GDP的大约90%花在……是的，花在他自己的加冕典礼上。但他还抽出时间把这些钻石送给吉斯卡尔，因为当时的法国总统作为他们将自己塑造为美国制衡力量的自我形象的一部分，他们花了很多时间试图在后殖民时代的非洲建立影响力。而吉斯卡尔接受了来自马卡萨的这些钻石。这随后被法国讽刺杂志《查理周刊》（注：原文为Le Canard Enchaîné，应为鸭鸣报）曝光。吉斯卡尔勃然大怒，称指控他接受
these diamonds, although he clearly has taken them. But's also he's also a bad man tom i think in the on the marital front um so supposedly i mean there's all kinds of doesn't it's what's very unclear whether he did or did not have a relationship with sylvie christel the star of the emmanuel um soft porn films in the 70s what is definitely true is that he used to meet people for assignations at a very aptly named hostelry called Le Petit Cocochon, which is the little cock in the field. Yeah. And he would leave sealed notes with his aides to say, this is where you can find me if there's a nuclear war or some sort of emergency.
这些钻石是一种绝对的耻辱，尽管他显然已经收下了。但同时他也是个坏男人，汤姆，我想在婚姻方面……所以据说——各种传言都有，很不清楚他究竟有没有和70年代《艾曼妞》软色情电影明星西尔维娅·克里斯泰尔发生过关系。确定无疑的是，他过去常常在一个名字非常贴切的名为“小公鸡”的旅店与人幽会，那是田野里的小公鸡。是的。他会给他的助手留下密封的便条，说：如果发生核战争或某种紧急情况，你在哪里可以找到我。
Because he was always somewhere different he carried it into his old age didn't he because he he famously notoriously uh wrote a kind of semi-pornographic novel about him and and princess diana who who appears as patricia princess of cardiff and it's all about the french president and yeah he's called princess of cardiff it's called Jacques-Henri Lambetti. Who could he be writing about? But you know where he seduces the Princess of Cardiff? Remind me.
因为他总是呆在不同的地方，他把这种习惯带到了晚年，不是吗？因为他众所周知地……写了一部关于他自己的半色情小说，主角是他和卡迪夫公主黛安娜——黛安娜以“卡迪夫公主帕特里夏”的身份出现，通篇都在写法国总统和……是的，她叫卡迪夫公主，书名叫《雅克-亨利·兰贝蒂》。他会是在写谁呢？但你知道他在哪里诱惑卡迪夫公主吗？提醒我一下。
On a train coming back from a ceremony to memorialise the D-Day landing. Oh. Oh. I mean, his direct contemporary, James Callaghan, Tom,
在一列从诺曼底登陆纪念仪式返回的火车上。哦。我的意思是，他同时代的直接同行，詹姆斯·卡拉汉，汤姆，
would never have written an erotic novel. No. No. Nor james callaghan tom would never have written an erotic novel no no nor nor had uh james callaghan lived to the age of 93 would he have been accused of um groping a german journalist that's right about two years ago it was two years before he before he died at the age of 95 in 2020 wow so i mean that is i mean the thing about she's guy i think is she's guy has absolutely no sense of himself as a comic character at all. I don't know how many French listeners or Francophone listeners we have, but maybe they can enlighten us as to whether people in France
绝不会写一本色情小说。不。不。詹姆斯·卡拉汉，汤姆，也绝不会写一本色情小说，不，不，如果詹姆斯·卡拉汉活到93岁，他也不会被指控……对一名德国女记者进行咸猪手，没错，那是在他2020年以95岁高龄去世前大约两年前的事情，哇。所以我的意思是，关于吉斯卡尔，我认为吉斯卡尔完全没有把自己当成一个喜剧人物的意识。我不知道我们有多少法国听众或法语听众，但也许他们可以启发我们，法国人是否
see Giscard as an essentially comic figure or whether they share his sense of his own tremendous importance. Well, he's a loser, isn't he? Because he ends up losing on the back of the Bacasa Diamond scandal to, for the first time, a left-wing president. That's right, François Mitterrand. And just one other thing on Giscard. Giscard, when you sort of study French presidential politics, they're only sort of, it's like one of those soap operas where there are only really 10 characters. Because they just spend all their time feuding with each other. And one of the great feuds in French politics is between Giscard and a subsequent right-wing president, Jacques Chirac.
将吉斯卡尔视为一个本质上的喜剧人物，还是他们分享了他那种认为自己极其重要的自我感觉。嗯，他是个失败者，不是吗？因为他最终在巴卡萨钻石丑闻的背景下，输给了一位左翼总统，这是第一次。没错，弗朗索瓦·密特朗。关于吉斯卡尔，还有一件事。吉斯卡尔，当你研究法国总统政治时，只有那么……这就像那种只有大约10个角色的肥皂剧。因为他们把所有时间都花在互相争斗上了。法国政治中最伟大的争端之一，就是吉斯卡尔与后来的右翼总统雅克·希拉克之间的争端。
And because Chirac runs against Giscard in 1981 and then doesn't really properly endorse him. That feud probably opens the door for François Mitterrand. So that is all for today's pod. But on tomorrow's episode, we will be covering Mitterrand. So that is all for today's pod. But on tomorrow's episode, we will be covering Mitterrand and Chirac and Sarkozy and, of course, the excellently named François Hollande and Emmanuel Macron and the shadowy figures of the Le Pens. However, if you simply can't wait until tomorrow, sign up to the Rest Is History Club, where you'll have the next episode straight away.
因为希拉克在1981年与吉斯卡尔竞选，随后并没有真正地全力支持他。这场争端可能为弗朗索瓦·密特朗打开了大门。今天的播客就到这里。但在明天的节目中，我们将讨论密特朗。今天的播客就到这里。但在明天的节目中，我们将讨论密特朗、希拉克、萨科齐，当然还有名字很棒的弗朗索瓦·奥朗德和埃马纽埃尔·马克龙，以及勒庞家族的阴影人物。然而，如果你实在等不到明天，请加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部，你将立即收听下一期节目。
Just go to the restishistorypod.com, restishistorypod.com, and we will see you then. A bientot. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
只需访问restishistorypod.com，restishistorypod.com，我们到时见。再见。感谢收听《历史就是一切》。想要收听独家加更、提前尝鲜、无广告版以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. TheRestIsEntertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》。TheRestIsEntertainment.com 本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。